so mm-hmm okay well I'll ask that
question again
I don't spit everywhere I like it when
people mess up their lines oh my gosh my
favorite thing or fall on ice
it's just don't two of my favorite
things hey guys I'm either sharp and we
have a really special guest here in the
kitchen with us Nia Vardalos is here to
chat a little bit about Greek food and
culture and the new movies My Big Fat
Greek Wedding - we are so excited that
the sequel is finally here
and I'm so glad that you're here in the
kitchen a couple of thoughts me too it's
really cool to be in here and you're
back in Toronto yep we're back in there
oh no and we both went to Ryerson we did
so a little bonding here and do you
remember the chair we didn't have one
but let's make one that's doing it okay
ready rah-rah myosin yeah that is great
we should copyright a totally sure yeah
doctor cooking I thought we would do a
little take on a traditional Greek
recipe a Greek salad oh great but my
take is a crispy chickpea kale salad
with a little to dekeydra's all probably
all know a middle-eastern take on the
whole thing
I thought we'd get started with the
dressing and I'm gonna put you to work
okay is this oh yeah okay okay so first
things first we've got a combination of
a little bit of honey and some Dijon
mustard so we do have the olive oil
going in okay so that's going in and I'm
using lemon juice because I really like
the brightness of that kind of the lemon
with the kale and I don't know if you've
ever tried this before but it's not
oregano it's called Zatara have you
tried something yeah that's so good on
bread so doctor has a Middle Eastern
spice blend and actually has oregano in
it so I figured it was fun of a nice
line that's great it's a good time and a
little bit of salt
of course great if you want to just give
that a quick little whisk up gray up
alright so dressing in great you
actually would massage even a massage
and kale yes actually that was my job
during college well it sounds like a
great job kale Jim let's make a little
Susie
so tzatziki in your family I don't know
what do you guys normally put it we it's
yogurt and strange cucumber and garlic
what are your thoughts on Greek yogurt
yogurt
do you like a full bags you like yogurt
yes and a full fat all the way there's
no such thing as dieting in the Greek
I'm sure I got that that is just it
doesn't make sense so you put garlic you
put lemon juice you put dill and you put
cucumber dreams cucumber which by the
way you could save so much money on
therapy if you just take a cucumber and
squash it to all the waters that event
rue you're not better and then you could
make to see can be a really happy person
exactly so I have already drained a twin
chickpeas I pack the drives a little
paper towel to absorb any excess
moisture so you can just cut these onto
my baking sheet when I get out of course
add some pepper and lots of salt and
lots of all
so while that is roasting up why don't
we talk a little bit about the DVD
release in everybody's funny the entire
original cast came back from the first
film to the second film everyone wow you
guys have had like such a good bond yeah
nobody wanted to give up the opportunity
well you know when you're making a movie
you never know what's gonna happen so I
have just one request sunset and that
it's fun it has to be fun because
everyone could be somewhere else
they could be on a higher-paying movie
or they could be home drinking a beer on
their front lawn so if you're gonna be
on the set at 4 5 6 a.m. it's got to be
fun and this pass definitely knows how
to party yeah did you grow up in a
kitchen where food was a really integral
part yes food plays a big part in my
family because all the women were in the
kitchen and that's where you heard all
the gossip all the things that people
would say about I have a son for you or
not to Macon yeah all the things that we
would discuss from matchmaking to who's
going to Greece this summer to the best
hair removal products that's a very
important conversation yeah yeah and I
would like to be real nice all right so
I think the chickpeas are ready I can
just gonna take a look wow that was so
easy how you did now music mmm all right
so now we kind of build the solid okay
the fun part so we're starting with a
little bit of that kale base you want to
grab some those beautiful too
some bell pepper this is choice on
Bernie yep
so yep let's get the olives ooh all
right all right pine nuts so now it's
kind of where we're doing that
Middle Eastern influence in there all
right some pomegranate seeds
we chose the combination for those yeah
so we're gonna go in with what's that
that you're putting on so this is sumac
could you tried suma I have it it's kind
of got a lemony flavor to it
Wow really great and of course we cannot
forget about those crispy chickpeas that
we just added
yes I want to get a little bit of that
crunch it add some protein too and then
we can't forget about this Mississippi
doesn't go now we get to eat yeah the
super pork on hand yeah I just have one
remark hurt obviously you never know
you're going through a restaurant you
see someone has really good food at
their table just take that fork out of
your first and try it people are quite
agreeable to that Lee we're Canadian
that's perfect that's a perfect salad I
think this kale was meant well massage
it was you did a really great job all
that practice from from University and
really paid off
I'm a preacher well thank you so much me
for coming by tech so having me so I'm
super excited to be able to watch My Big
Fat Greek Wedding - anytime I want tell
us how it's available oh you can watch
it anytime you want digitally or you can
buy the blu-ray or DVD and we added in
some little back behind the scenes
extras there so it's really really it's
good for the whole family to watch I
love that well thanks again guys if you
liked what you saw and give us a thumbs
up maybe for thumbs up yeah maybe for
you could do one two three four
we've got me here so yes I'm just gonna
hit the channel books to my car me
message below about what kind of dishes
you like me acaba come back here what
and I'll see you next time on Ali's
kitchen I don't think we're gonna share
that I'll share sharing means caring man
man good they're really good